our women's brains different from men's
the question is meant to provoke and yet
young women are much less likely to
choose to study technical subjects such
as mathematics science and engineering
so why is that with a degree in
education in Jana Rodriguez is
responsible for a report on school and
university courses you have a lot of
stereotypes in our society you can have
advisors for girls and of course for
boys too but it'll be very important to
advise girls which areas they should go
because usually they go for indications
area all cares area so doesn't make any
sense in our day the Committee on
women's rights and gender equality voted
in favor of a series of recommendations
to encourage more girls to study science
related subjects the text also mentions
incentives to increase the number of men
working in nurseries and primary
education you need to have a good
balance in basically every and each
sector of our life and also of course in
school in preschool in kindergarten and
universities so many p's voted against
the report finding it to ideological
member states still need convincing